once upon a time software updates came
on a cd-rom via snail mail but not
anymore to remain competitive company
ship code multiple times a day
for example Amazon developers release
code on average every eleven point seven
seconds DevOps is the combination of
cultural philosophies practices and
tools that increase businesses ability
to deliver applications and services at
high velocity and to deliver them at
scale and on a continually evolving
basis Udacity snoo cloud devops NAMM
degree program teaches you all the
practical skills necessary to deliver
code faster more securely and at scale
in just a few short months you'll learn
how to deploy massive infrastructure and
apps with code you'll learn continuous
deployment continuous integration
pipelines and work with microcircuit
scale whether you come from a software
development or operations background
Udacity snoo cloud devops nanodegree
program is for you
it will supplement your skill set using
new real world projects enroll in
Udacity cloud DevOps nano degree program
today